الطاقة النووية في العالم بتدشين
محطة اكيو النووية الجديدة وان
العامين المتبقيين في فترة
ولايته وذلك وفق وكالة يوهاب.
بايدن قائلة انه رجل عجوز خريف
بلا مستقبل. ومن الصعب عليه يكمل
وسول. حيث كثف الحلفاء الردع
النووي في مواجهة بيونج يانج
ان بلادها ستعزز قوتها ردا على
الاتفاقية الجديدة بين واشنطن
الاحداث والتطورات. قالت شقيقة
زعيم كوريا الشمالية كيميو جونغ
وجميع المنافذ المؤدية اليها.
ليرسل حميتي رسالة قائلا رسالتي
السريع سيطرتها المحكمة على
تسعين بالمائة من ولاية الخرطوم
لاجبار السكان المدنيين على
اخلاء هذه المناطق لاستخدامها
الانسانية والقيام بعمليات
عسكرية في العاصمة الخرطوم. حيث
اصحاب العيون الضيقة الى الحدود
الصينية الهندية. حيث اندلعت
الوزارة ان عدة طائرات حلقت عبر
خط الوسط في مضيق تايوان الذي
مقاتلة وطائرات حربية اخرى
للتحليق بالقرب من واضافت
اثر هجوم طائرة مسيرة في
المنطقة. واضاف بان الحريق صعب
كييف على القتال في المناطق
المأهولة بالسكان تأهبا للهجوم
قريبا جدا. ويضطران للتنحي عن
السلطة وذلك بسبب المخاطر التي
افادت وكالة الانباء السورية بان
الجيش السوري تصدى لهجوم
المحطة ستوفر نحو عشرين بالمائة
من الطاقة التي تحتاجها البلاد.
وبينما لم يحدد الاوكران موعد
هجومهم المضاد. جاء طباخ بوتين
اسرائيلي بالصواريخ على حمص
واسقط بعضها. الهجوم المضاد هو
كمرابض للمدافع وللقناصة على
البنايات العالية منها. هناك
نقاتلكم مؤكدا على انه مستعد
لاجراء مفاوضات شرط وقف اطلاق
بوتيرة متقطعة وسط تبادل
للاتهامات بشأن خرق الهدنة
النار بحسب شبكة بي بي سي. فهل
يقترب الطرفان من الحوار?
اعلنت نقابة اطباء السودان عن
سقوط اربعمائة واحد عشر قتيلا من
الاشتباكات بين قوات الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
استمر القصف العشوائي بالمدافع
في بحر وام درمان والخرطوم
المدنيين فقط دون العسكريين
والفين وثلاثة وعشرين مصابا منذ
اوكرانيا يقول انه يؤمن بنجاح
الهجوم المضاد المرتقب. منوها
الشغل الشاغل للاوكران وحلفائهم.
فهل ياتي هذا الهجوم بالغرض? ام
الهدن المتلاحقة اوقفت نزيف الدم
السوداني ليستمر ومعه تستمر
جديد في مواجهة مباشرة في اي وقت
فمتى تنطلق ساعة الصفر اذا.
الحدودي التاريخي في ومع حشد
الجارتين قوتهما على الحدود منذ
الدفاع التايوانية تقول ان الجيش
الصيني ارسل ثمان وثلاثين طائرة
يفصل الجزيرة عن البر الرئيسي.
نعم اصحاب العيون الضيقة يطوقون
قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان ان بلاده دخلت نادي دول
النتنة وبالعودة لاوكرانيا هنا
اعلنت الخدمة الصحفية للواء
السودان يغوص في الوحل. لا الحرب
حسمت المواقف في السودان ولا
الجنوبية يعكس ارادة الحلفاء
الاكثر عدائية وعدوانية ضد
هناك اعتبرت كيم يو ان الاتفاق
بين الولايات المتحدة وكوريا
تحرش الاوكران بجارتهم فكيف
سيكون رد مسك? بكين تنطلق نحو
التصرفات من جانب بولندا تعد
وضيعة ليأتي الرد الحقيقي من
سنوات تبدو هذه المنطقة قنبلة
موقوتة تهدد بانزلاق الجارتين من
الدفاع الاقليمي مائة وعشرين
المنفصل للقوات الاوكرانية عن
السفارة الروسية في وارسو ليقول
السفير الروسي في بولندا. ان
موسكو لن تترك ما اقدمت عليه
السلطات البولندية بينما اعلنت
اجراء قوات كييب تدريبات بالقرب
من الحدود مع بيلاروس مع هنا
وعشرين جنديا اوكرانيا على كافة
المحاور خلال يوم واحد. فيال هذه
ديمتري ميدفيديف الذي قال
اوكرانيا مليئة بالمرتزقة
جزيرة تايوان من الجو. فهل بدأ
الغزو الصيني للجزيرة لننتقل مع
لقوات الجيش اننا لا نريد
محاربتكم. عودوا الى ثكناتكم ولن
بداية الاشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم. لتؤكد قوات الدعم
اهدافها. انتهى وقت التصريحات
وانتهت صلاحيات التحذيرات. حرب
الشمال وفق تعبيرها. لتوجه
بوصلتها نحو الرئيس الامريكي جو
التحذيرات المتبادلة بين الصين
والهند من مغبة اشتعال النزاع
الكلام ما عادت تنفع فهي حرب
باردة يا سادة. ها هي وزارة
الارقام المرعبة ان صحت تصريحات
الدفاع الروسية والمصدر موقع
من هجوم نتساءل حتى نحن عن كيف
سيكون. اما على الارض فاعلنت
ومن الحرب الاوكرانية الى
الاراضي البولندية حيث ارتفعت
الريح واكثر من ثمانمائة قتيل من
القوات الاوكرانية بسبب الهجمات
الاوكراني المضاد بحسب صحيفة
بيلد. لتعود الصحيفة وتنوه بان
البولنديين الذين يجب القضاء
عليهم بلا رحمة مثل الفئران
تهدد كييف في حال استمرار
العملية العسكرية الخاصة. اضافة
بينما قد يفقد رئيسا اوكرانيا
وامريكا كرسيي الحكم في بلديهما.
فقد افادت صحيفة بانزال النسكي
وجو بايدن قد يخسران منصبيهما
مروحية توكرانية في لوجانسك
وتصفية اكثر من ثمانمائة وخمسة
اسبوعاني هذا قوات كييف للتحضير
لهجوم لكن عن اي هجوم نتحدث
القواعد الالمانية تضم حاليا
اكثر من الف جندي اوكراني فيا له
وزارة الدفاع الروسية تدمير اربع
عشرة مسيرة اوكرانية في واسقاط
الحياد. الهجوم المضاد هو حلم
الاوكرانيين الذين يعيشون على
مستعد لتنفيذ هجومه المضاد قبل
الخامس عشر من مايو المقبل. بقي
سيباستوبل وشبه جزيرة القرم هي
آآ نتيجة آآ عقاب من الله.
روسيا اليوم.
وزارة الخارجية الروسية انها
سترد بقسوة. لافتة الى ان هذه
حدة التوتر بين روسيا وبولندا
وذلك بعد حادثة اقتحام مدرسة
المانيا على الخط حيث يعمل
المدربون الالمان على تدريب قوات
الصحيفة ذاتها. ومع كل هذا
الانتظار للهجوم الاوكراني. دخلت
العسكرية الاوكرانية اندريه اه
يسوف والذي اكد بان في مدينة
يفجين بريجوجن ليعلن عن الموعد.
حيث قال ان الجيش الاوكراني
بسبب كمية الوقود موجودة في
الخزان. هناك وجهت موسكو اعين
المصدر. التعليق الوحيد كان من
المتحدث باسم الاستخبارات
عقاب من الله لبوتين وروسيا نحن
لم نأتي بشيء من رؤوسنا. اليكم
اتهاماتها لكييف. لكن
الاستخبارات الاوكرانية تنفي
ميدفيديف بقوله يواصل كلب كييف
النباح. هذا الهجوم المرتقب الهب
الى ان المخزونات العسكرية لدى
الولايات المتحدة شبه معدومة وفق
احلام يا سادة. ليجيب نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي ديمتري
القرم ميخائيل رازفوجيف ان حريقا
اندلع في خزان وقود في المدينة
تسببها بهذه الهجمة وتقول ان
انفجارات شبه جزيرة القرن هي
صحيفة واي ال اي الفنلندية. هل
يتحدث من الواقع? ام انها اضغاث
باعتقاده بانه سيكون قادرا على
استعادة شبه جزيرة القرم وفق
الحماسة في صدور الاوكران. ليعلن
حاكم سيفاستوبول بشبه جزيرة
امله ويستبسلون من اجله ويستمتون
في الدفاع بسببه. نعم ها هو رئيس
ببلاروسيا. الصين تستعد لابتلاع
تايوان من الجو. والحدود الهندية
الروسية خلال اربع وعشرين ساعة.
واوكرانيا تتحرش عسكريا
تتحدى الولايات المتحدة على
العلن وتركيا تدخل نادي الدول
قنبلة موقوتة تكاد تنفجر بين
بكين ونيودلهي. كوريا الشمالية
النووية. هجوم كييف المضاد.
دعونا نتحدث بحياد الحياد ثم
البولنديين كالفئران. ومنصب جو
بايدن وسيلنسك الرئاسية في مهب
انها مجرد زوبعات اعلامية?
هذه الهجمات هي عقاب من الله
لبوتين وروسيا. نعم هكذا سخرت
كييف من روسيا وموسكو ترد. يواصل
النباح وميدفيديف سنقضي على